[Music]
matthew's with us in boston hey matthew
welcome to the ramsey show
hi uh thanks for taking my call dave how
you doing better than i deserve what's
up
um i've got i guess it's going to be a
not necessarily complex question but
i've got
about 1.2 million
in investment debt
um the value is about 2.3
million um and then personally i've got
a mortgage of
925 000
my combined family income is 230 000.
i'm i didn't find you until about july
of this year so i've adjusted i'm
technically in between baby step five
and six
so i'm trying to find out i've got some
extra cash i've got about 150
and 150 000 extra cash that i was either
going to invest or start to target and
pay down my investment mortgages gotcha
i just don't know which direction to go
well i would begin to clear the
mortgages because that's going to lower
the risk of the portfolio dramatically
um i mean you got about a 35 equity
position so you got a pretty good equity
position but
um but but i like 100 equity position
and that's what i've got in my real
estate and what i recommend
so i i mean you're sitting there with
two million dollars worth of real estate
paid for plus a paid four million dollar
house
you can breathe man that's a whole
different world that would be pretty
cool and you're about two million
dollars away from doing that so got 150
000 start the process and 200 000 income
um so what is your smallest the 1.2 is
how many properties
four 53. three what's the smallest
mortgage
uh 253 000. okay
all right there's two things i look at
when i'm look when i'm considering doing
this if i'm in your shoes
uh thing one i look at is i try to work
a debt snowball pay off the smallest to
the largest that's one thing to consider
um the second thing i look at is
something happens in my 30 years of
experience of doing this
when your home is paid off
something happens inside of your soul
that's different than paying off your
rental
so
and there's a bit of a risk management
thing in there too if you if you had to
choose in a horrible situation which
property you were going to lose
because you couldn't pay the bill you
would choose to lose the rental before
you choose to lose your residence
absolutely and so for that reason i
generally put the house at the front
of the real estate
uh to get paid off now you've got a
house that's you almost as much on as
you do four properties so
um that makes it a little more difficult
but if you had a rental say somebody
called me and they said hey i've got oh
200 000 on my house and i owe
180 000 on my rental i would say let's
get your house knocked out
because of risk management does that
make sense
but in your so those those are the
things run through my head while i'm
answering your question
um the principles that i that i kind of
use as my guidelines
um
so if i woke up in your shoes i probably
pay off the smallest rental asap use 150
towards it and then just take a bunch of
your income chunk towards it and then
i'm probably going to just take
everything else i can
drag off the table
i'm sorry the next rental property is
uh so it's 253 394. yeah so if i pay off
the 253 then roll it into the 394. now
i'll take that i pay off the 253 and
then i would roll it into your home
into my primary yeah i'd flip i'm going
to knock out that little one just to
create some more cash
because that thing will cash flow like a
bandit when it's paid off
and then i'm gonna do that i'm trying to
create some cash and and then i'm gonna
put that cash with your great cash and
then i'm gonna start chunking on your
house it'll probably take you three
maybe four years knock your house out
and then you'll flip over and start
knocking those rentals out after those
other two of the three rental debts out
after that then when all of that is paid
for you're going to have so much cash
you're not going to know what to do with
i just sat down with our cfo this
morning going over our rental properties
because it's time to start planning
taxes
and um you know when you don't have any
payments on rentals
they
they make money that's a lot of cash
yeah and so you get these things all
paid off in the future then you'll be
able to buy another rental with cash
pretty quick and then another rental
with cash even faster so i'm not a real
estate i'm not there
why wouldn't you
liquidate those rental properties and
just pay your house off and square up
you could okay you could um
i'm at this point in your million
dollars
of equity in right
i'm reading into this because he didn't
even bring that up
uh and he's
prob i was reading and i was reading
into this that he's pretty emotionally
invested in those into that whole
process
and cleaning it up is an option selling
them all probably not something he's
going to consider doing
that is something you could do or you
could do a partial of that you could
pick one of the four
and dump it yep take that equity and
accelerate this process and then go back
and replace it later or pick one of the
four that yeah the one of the four you
could pick would either be the a peach
that had a lot of equity to make it go
faster or you could uh pick the one you
don't like yeah of the four i got one i
got one you know uh winston rachel's
husband manages hours and we were
talking about it at breakfast of the
morning goes well if we didn't own such
and such an address we'd never buy it
again and i went oh well that's true we
wouldn't but we've got it so we're going
to keep it but if we you know we're
talking about what we're going to do the
next five years it goes we'll never buy
one of those and he named that street
name
you know and you're right i would never
buy that one again so that that'd be the
one i would sell if i was trying to
accelerate something over on my side i'm
not i'm just buying hole but um but
that's yeah you could liquidate them all
and just 100 pay off everything today
yeah
uh but then you have to start over on
the rental that's right and i'm guessing
he's not going to do that now i'm
guessing that matthew is probably
pretty
pretty invested emotionally in this
whole process and so yeah but you know
that bringing that up makes me think
about selling one of them for sure
i like the idea of selling one of them
taking 150 000 cash and suddenly i'm i'm
almost halfway done with my mortgage
over you know overnight and
uh maybe that's too simplistic and there
may be more there's mortgages against
the other ones so it's not quite that
that the math not quite that clean but
um i i you said something that was
important there's something about having
a paid off house that
just changes everything
i think um
i don't think when we went broke i
understood the borrower or slave to the
lender because they took stuff from me
uh
you know and i'm worried about the car
being reported i'd go out in the morning
and wonder if it was going to be there
uh and that kind of stuff going through
the bankruptcy and uh so that that
i had a whole new perception on debt
after that and the power it has over you
spiritually yeah emotionally
uh
that was one time i experienced the
weight and the truth of that scripture
the second time was when i was 100 debt
free
after i paid off the house and
everything is done
and you do walk out in the backyard with
no shoes and the grass feels different
under your feet and something snaps
there's a peace button
inside of you that flips so do you know
how many americans
are a percentage of homeowners have a
mortgage
uh about half oddly enough wow i thought
it'd be way higher i did two i just got
fresh numbers the other day about half
are paid off so
i've been
one of my core tenants one of my core
beliefs about psychology is you can't be
mentally well if you are not in control
of your tomorrow and it hit me i've been
here almost two years now
wait a minute if you owe somebody money
you cannot be psychologically well
because a part of your brain knows we're
not in control of tomorrow and if you
don't believe me just walk through a
pandemic wow you find out you're not the
third pig in the brick house you're the
one in the sticks in the
hay house you pay that mortgage off and
you can breathe yeah it's a different
thing